[Música]
una tierra herida lastimada donde el
tiempo parece haberse congelado en estos
pueblos sacrificados
y en estos cientos de miles de soldados
caídos durante trescientos días de
combates despiadados
este lugar de memoria histórica les
recuerda a los vivos la importancia del
sacrificio de estos hombres
uno siempre se siente sobrecogido en un
cementerio se leen los nombres de su
edad
verdú es una palabra que resume por sí
sola la primera guerra mundial
hoy en día ya no quedan agua luz para
contar cómo era el infierno de los
combates
pero cada tanto los muertos siguen
revelando algunos secretos
buenos días estamos terminando la
limpieza
son huesos del fuerte de tu amor cada
año surgen nuevos restos de la tierra y
con cada descubrimiento juliette y el
médico forense de berdún llevan a cabo
una investigación cada objeto
recolectado es cuidadosamente limpiado
con un respeto infinito a la noche de
los hechos si éste lo anudó de manera
consciente antes de salir al ataque y
quedó intacto al azar
[Música]
porque él quedó fulminado por los
disparos austriaca del ataque y la
bestia del este
lo mejor es cuando encontramos una placa
de matrícula militar porque ahí podemos
remontarnos hasta una familia unos
descendientes es encontrar la foto del
soldado en 1914 eso es algo sensacional
esta herencia increíble también debe ser
transmitida al público es el trabajo de
esta guía franco-alemana
desde hace casi 40 años recorre estas
tierras heridas y en particular estas
galerías subterráneas bajo la colina de
boko a que se extienden sobre varios
kilómetros
me gusta mucho hacer recorridos por aquí
porque es un campo de batalla muy
excepcional el único en el que se puede
ingresar a los subterráneos aquí la
guerra se vive en carne propia claro sí
sí una faceta totalmente olvidada de
esta guerra atroz en estos túneles
franceses y alemanes a veces estaban a
tan solo unas decenas de metros los unos
de los otros y esto era para los
soldados franceses de tom keys mientras
estaban en la colina se quedaban a veces
diez o doce horas haciendo su trabajo
montando guardia y todo eso entonces
tenían pequeños cuartos así para comer o
para descansar un poco un calvario bajo
tierra que las generaciones actuales a
veces no logran entender muy bien
siempre hago mi mejor esfuerzo por
explicarles cómo vivían las personas en
esa época a spock y que era mucho más
duro de lo que es para nosotros hoy en
día hoy somos privilegiados no
soportaríamos una vida como esta por
mucho tiempo
esta vida en el barro y bajo las bombas
es la que la guía comparte a diario con
turistas alemanes
en el fuerte de tu amor trata de
devolverlos a 1916
eso fue una explosión muy pequeña
en los fuertes de la región había
explosiones como esta en promedio unas
dos mil veces al día
y exploten
uno no se imagina el diluvio de fuego y
la increíble masacre humana que vivieron
aquí eso nunca más vuelva a ocurrir
darle vida a esta dramática historia y
volverla accesible es también el trabajo
que hacen juliette y bruno en los
colegios de la ciudad
en esta clase de primaria presentan sus
trabajos de investigación
que siempre inician con los restos de
los soldados
cuando encontramos jueces por lo general
también encontramos objetos de su resto
era un pequeño cuchillo
y también encontramos municiones de
guerra por eso no tocamos más
para hablar sobre los polio el médico no
trajo huesos sino objetos encontrados
alrededor de los cuerpos como pueden ver
esto es un bidón es una fiambrera donde
ponían la comida
es igual que los botones así como tú
tienes un botón en tu pantalón esto es
lo mismo
si satisfacen puntos libres
de halcón pachuca
[Música]
a su edad yo tenía a mis dos abuelos
ellos no tienen eso pero es nuestra
tarea reemplazar a aquellos que
conocimos y que nos contaban todas las
historias
en berdún muchas familias no han
terminado su duelo porque hasta el día
de hoy los cuerpos de unos 60.000
soldados aún no han aparecido